como se desarrollaron los hechos desde
el interior del recinto
bueno buenas noches
estimados compañeros y quiero
comentarles como nosotros vivimos
con grave la repubblica la experiencia
del día de hoy y para la dos de la tarde
nosotros teníamos convocado a funcionar
pleno y en el cual vamos a proceder con
la interpelación y vícar inquilina en
este momento que debe presidir esta
moción a dos de la tarde ya te miraba el
exterior de la república con más de
ochocientas personas debilitar es y
tomando alrededores de el congreso de la
república
fuimos alrededor de 13 diputados lo que
le vamos a ingresar al municipio y al en
20 30 minutos de estar dentro del
hemiciclo y nos comentaron que estaba
totalmente
bloquean el quemado y que en grecia en
artística por xxi militares
el congreso de la república
principalmente lleno de sus trabajadores
de recursos humanos de aplicativos
estaba también como vitoriano un
ministro de estado y nos recordamos en
paz y de una hora y media dentro del
ingreso de la república algo que nos
preocupa grandemente que el ministro de
gobernación no haya reaccionado de forma
rápida en este momento afectaba muy de
ver que tenían armas blancas y
destrozaron en la puerta del parque o el
congreso de la república
incendiaron de prendieron fuego a varios
de los vehículos que se encontraban en
el parque o si el congreso de la
república y destruyeron nuestras
oficinas de la bancada de oposición
creo que con violencia no se puede
llegar a acuerdos el señor presidente
debe darle la cara a estos ex militares
y también instamos a la junta directiva
a dar la cara con su integrantes de la
junta directiva no son costaban
la
diputada puede hablarnos de esta
iniciativa que planea la compensación
económica a los exmilitares como
mencionaba emiliano se sabe que fue
parte de la campaña del presidente
alejandro giammatei pero cuál es el
estado de este proyecto
bueno esta iniciativa como como bien
común ya no hay presidentes de los
prometió en campañas militares es una
ley de compensación económica
si se pretende adaptar a más de 90
militares lo que había dicho
cada uno de ellos y un compromiso del
primer presidente al no estar aprobar la
república y tiene varias lecturas que
deben de proceder por las operaciones no
se ha aprobado en este momento y no se
ha agendado tampoco en la agenda
legislativa a pesar de que el presidente
es el que tiene la mayoría de
modificados en el congreso de la
república la vida alta oficialista y
ayer demostró que tiene la fuerza de 101
votos de los 170 disparos yo somos así
que hace más que suficiente para que él
pueda corregir las primeras si bien la
pac son los mejores militares